gandhi
salemi mussomeli e cammarata
questi sono quattro comuni siciliani
ma cos'hanno in comune fra di loro e
cosa hanno in comune con tanti altri
borghi sparsi in tutta italia che tutti
e quattro hanno puntato sulla
rigenerazione urbana hanno scelto cioè
di non far morire il loro patrimonio
immobiliare che spesso anche un
patrimonio artistico e culturale di
puntare sull'operazione di rigenerazione
urbana di cui sicuramente avrete sentito
parlare
ogni tanto che quella di vendere le case
a un euro
io sono sempre stata affascinata dalla
rigenerazione e la passione per la
rigenerazione delle cose vecchie che
hanno una storia mi ha portato anche a
farne il mio lavoro come diceva
dall'inizio per cui otto anni fa ho
creato la mia attività di impresa che
oggi anche la mia attività principale
scegliendo di ridare nuova vita a ciò
che viene considerato un rifiuto o
rifiuto speciale e in questi anni ho
trasformato migliaia di scarti di
aziende e privati dei materiali più
disparati in altrettanti gadget
aziendali oggetti di design arredi e
allestimenti e la passione per la
rigenerazione mi ha portato a fare
un'altra esperienza importante circa sei
anni fa ho sentito parlare durante una
startup weekend di farm cultural park
un progetto nato grazie a una coppia di
sposi andrea florinda bartoli notaio lui
avvocato lei che proprio sulla
riflessione sulla casa su dove comprare
casa loro vivevano a parigi in quel
momento insieme alle bimbe piccolissime
decidono di comprare casa non a parigi
ma a favara di tornare nella loro città
di origine per far vivere le bambine
accanto agli effetti accanto ai
familiari e canta in ogni insomma e gli
zii ma si fanno una promessa
andrea e florinda si dicono se torniamo
non ci dobbiamo lamentare e scelgono di
tornare e impegnarsi per creare un
futuro migliore per le loro bambine e
non soltanto varcarle viola ma anche per
tutti i bambini di favara e per la città
di favara e fondono quello che oggi è il
farmaco ltro il pack che viene
considerato uno dei centri culturali
indipendenti più interessanti al mondo
per l'arte contemporanea quello che
avviene a favara grazie alla farm che
attira turisti e visitatori da tutto il
mondo crea un indotto che trasforma pian
piano il centro storico e favara
oggi è una capitale mondiale di
rigenerazione urbana
sento parlare di questa storia dico voi
andava a vedere con i miei occhi quindi
vado a favara e devo dirvi che l'impatto
non è stato dei migliori perché mentre
prendo questa strada provinciale che
sale su in collina
questo in cui questo degrado che vero
salendo per sulla collina insomma dove
sto a favara mi fa pensare ma dove sto
andando dove sono dove sono arrivata e
devo dire che anche l'impatto con la
città non so quanti di voi ci sono stati
anche un impatto wow cifra non è una
città bella tu arrivi eve di questa
città che di fatto è abbastanza bruttina
e anche trovare la farma all'interno del
centro storico la prima volta è stato
complicato io mi aspettavo nel mio
immaginario di trovare questi grandi
cartelli che indicassero dove era questo
luogo straordinario mentre non trovai
nulla arrivo nel centro storico che in
alcuni tratti sembrava semi abbandonato
o addirittura bombardata in tutto punto
entro in questo luogo è l'ingresso in
questo blog mi è sembrato veramente una
cosa straordinaria
sono entrato un luogo che a me sembrava
magico pienissimo di energia con la
bellezza e mise in proprio seminata in
ogni angolo e li conosco andrea
conoscono in da conosco diverse per fare
la farma torno vado per prendere l'auto
e tornare a casa che l'ha parcheggiata
in uno di questi vicoli stretti che
stanno a tornar la farma la certo punto
accanto l'auto vedo un enorme cartello
stile che ha co scritto compra anche tu
casa a favara 3.000 euro
boom cioè io ne fui folgorata non so mai
capitato di avere dentro un fuoco che vi
spinge a fare qualcosa subito no e io
dissi anche io compro casa a favara
ma perchè non comprarlo a gangi non
comprarla mussomeli a salemi a 2.999
euro in meno e comprarla lì perché a
favara
avevo appena conosciuto una comunità di
persone che volevano cambiare le cose
che come avevamo il desiderio di
cambiare il mondo di fare qualcosa di
impegnarsi e io volevo fare parte di
quella comunità volevo anch'io
partecipare a quel sogno collettivo
volevo fare il mio breve piccola parte
dal mio contributo per la venerazione di
quel centro storico e non di un altro a
questo punto diventa importante farvi
conoscere michele michele un architetto
straordinario una colonna portante della
farma è innamorato pazzo lo è il centro
storico di favara
in questa foto dove è seduto in un
angolo del centro storico la foto e
recente di qualche mese fa ancora alcune
zone del centro storico sono così amy
che l'ha investito nel centro storico
sicuramente che parte dei suoi soldi ma
tantissima energia ed è colui che ha
avuto la pazienza e la determinazione di
accompagnarmi per quattro anni in giro a
guardare a casa in vendita a favara ogni
volta che andavo alla fan per un
incontro che un appuntamento una parte
del tempo era dedicato alla ricerca di
questa casa che avrebbe preso una nuova
vita e devo dirvi che grazie insomma
questo sogno alla mia attività in quegli
anni andata meglio per cui quando
cominciai a cercare casa io nel conto
non avevo nemmeno i 3.000 euro
reclamizzati nel cartellone mentre nel
tempo a favore ha comprato la mia prima
casa ha comprato anche la seconda casa è
anche una terza e questo momento in cui
abbiamo proprio sancito questa questi
acquisti e subito decisi che una di
queste case doveva essere rigenerata e
quindi a darmi da fare in quel momento
lì alla pharma c'era una mostra una
mostra fotografica sulle share ed house
per le case condivide condivise
esperienze di colini neri tutto il mondo
allora grazie a quella mostra grazie una
chiacchierata con andrea che bratt e in
foto è con michele decisi che casa lupi
da questo è il nome che diede a quella
casa doveva essere la prima essere doubt
di favara una casa a vocazione turistica
ma con il desiderio che in quella casa
si potesse sperimentare quello che io
avevo sperimentata paparazzo è
l'importanza delle relazioni
l'importanza dei rapporti umani e quindi
nasce questa casa quindi rete un
ambiente questa foto la messa soltanto
per farvi vedere i miracoli che la
rigenerazione può fare questa è una
stanza una casa va letto ma gli ambienti
più importanti della casa sono la cucina
soggiorno e la terrazza che sono state
il progettare il mio come degli ambienti
da mettere in comune tutte le esperienze
di coli vini tutte le sere da sparse per
il mondo hanno degli ambienti privati
dove ognuno buon vivere la vita come
vuole e degli ambienti comuni da
dividere con i cohouser anche il primo
relatore ci parlava di questa esperienza
dico living dove poter condividere che
cosa interessi passioni dove poter avere
dei momenti di svago di gioco di relax
in alcuni casi in alcune esperienze nel
coli ving si condividono anche le spese
quindi si abbattono anche i costi di
gestione quotidiana e noi abbiamo
immaginato che in questi ambienti comuni
quindi nella terrazza messa a
disposizione n soggiorno pensati apposta
ospiti completamente sconosciuti fra di
loro potessero condividere incontrarsi
chiacchierare conoscersi magari mangiare
insieme poter condividere idee magari
condividere i propri talenti e fare
anche delle attività insieme immaginato
si volessero fare un altro dei corsi di
cucina siciliana nei laboratori creativi
oppure uno ospite carla di genova che
insegna yoga certo potremmo fare anche
dei corsi di yoga per bambini in
terrazza ecco in questo anno di vita di
casa dubita
abbiamo accolto tanti turisti e artisti
provenienti da tutto il mondo grazie una
sinergia straordinaria sicuramente con
michele che ha curato anche la
ristrutturazione della casa con andrea
con florinda con diverse persone della
farm ma tratti anche queste persone che
vedi qui in foto che sono mamma carmela
che poi la nonna il piccolo pietro la
zia carmela e angela che ha fatto la
foto che era persona chiave più
importante che non è voluta a comparire
sono i miei vicini di casa favaresi sono
quelli che abitano accanto casa
l'utilità li ho conosciuti per caso
mentre ero lì a sistemare delle cose
carmela mi chiama vuoi un caffè io la
prima volta di si no
la seconda alla terza di fano bisogna
farlo e da quel momento in poi mi hanno
adottata è diventata come una seconda
famiglia
non c'è volta in cui non vado a favara
dove l'eroe non si occupano di me ma non
solo con una generosità commovente loro
hanno accolto e coccolato tutti gli
ospiti casa novità
vedano le piante l'acqua quando non ci
sono solo che fanno prendere aria alla
casa quindi una sinergia straordinaria
anche insieme con loro
sicuramente c'è molto da fare ancora
tanta strada per casa dubita che ancora
agli inizi ma volevo mostrarvi dei
messaggi che sono lasciato alcuni ospiti
che sono stati in casa questi sono i
messaggi di jeff e thomas e che sono i
primissimi che mettono pietro in casale
pira sono due artisti americani avevano
dato una mano e collaborato per la
mostra detroit syndrome che sarà
inaugurata a farmi in giugno 2018 è il
loro dopo che stanno insomma un po di
tempo gli scrivono abbiamo riso molto
consolidato amicizie e legami poi
lasciano una serie di suggerimenti e
comprato la bambina che non funzionava
bene il phon cose che abbiamo
assolutamente risolto subito dopo
poi c'è un messaggio di elena ed olga
due siciliane che arrivano a fare
probabilmente un po come me non
capiscono dove sono arrivate insomma
hanno bisogno di qualcuno che el esteri
qualcosa
michele pasta un intero pomeriggio con
loro in casa lupi da raccontargli la
storia di farm del centro storico della
casa e lo lasciano la casa scrivendoci
così lupita è l'esempio di futuro
migliore c'è tutta la sicilia in questa
casa il calore la voglia di conoscere
quella di non fermarsi e ci scrivono non
fermatevi e poi messaggio di francesca
francesca romana una pellegrina aveva
fatto a piedi la magna via francigena da
palermo fino ad agrigento quindi a rivas
tramortita a favara chiede ospitalità e
condividere a casa con damiano e
francesco scrive arrivati qui per caso
dopo un lungo viaggio lontana sola a
trovarsi a casa un sogno concludo con il
desiderio per il futuro di casa novità è
che chiunque vi metta piede
chiunque vi sia ospite possa
sperimentare quello che io sperimentato
e che francesca espresso e cioè sentirsi
parte in qualche modo di qualcosa di più
grande e avere voglia di mettersi
relazione con chi fino a qualche momento
prima era semplicemente considerato
altro da te avere voglia di mettersi in
gioco e di sognare
beh perché la lezione che casa lupita mi
ha insegnato è che la rigenerazione vera
non sta negli edifici non sta nei
mourinho sta nei bei progetti di
architettura ma sta nei rapporti umani e
sta nella condivisione grazie